South Korea has only taken the world of
dota 2 by storm once in the game's
history and it was incredible
[Applause]
the chances are it'll never happen again
South Korea has dominated every game the
region has chosen to focus on from
Starcraft to League of Legends to
overwatch so you think the region would
be a powerhouse in a game as
sophisticated strategic and a lucrative
as dota 2
but they aren't mostly because they've
never really been given the chance to
play it when valve was first launching
dota 2
they gave necks on the rights to publish
and promote the game in South Korea the
issue is that Nexon took kind of a
hands-off approach to the whole thing
and by the time they actually got the
ball rolling
the League of Legends revolution was
well underway why do you think that
League is so much more popular than dota
I mean other people were say it's like
bad timing were like five shouldn't have
trusted Nixon love personally I think it
all comes down to the girls like yeah
there's no girls playing dota 2 so not a
lot of people we want to paint what I
feel or there's a lot of girls playing
yellow air yeah such a cultural thing
whatever game has like blue girls like
more guys will follow the game what's
more the original defense of the
ancients never took off in Korea the way
it did in North America Europe and
Southeast Asia
so dota 2 was being sold to an audience
that really didn't know what dota was to
begin with
as a result the game never really
managed to ingrain itself in the
countries PC box
well much on Kojima not even a stencil
Salinas reward so bottomland erisa
heritage means Nietzsche and ERISA you
don't pick over on the or illogical
today so you don't pick your own then
next I'll try to draw an internet cafe
customers by giving them access to
accelerated profile leveling and many
in-game items already unlocked they even
went so far is to offer customers their
very own compendium it was a strategy
that worked for League of Legends
for all their effort next one gave up on
dota pretty quickly not only the next on
stop supporting the region's dedicated
server and dota 2 at large in 2015 the
regional server the players were forced
to return to had become so plagued with
hacks and scams that was eventually
abandoned altogether and yet for two
glorious years there was one
organization that managed to defy all
the odds one ragtag roster who came
together to overthrow their regions
terrible dota infrastructure that
overcame mandatory military service and
in a fehmi's case overcame actual
homelessness to show the world that they
could be
[Applause]
that's once again the thing that made
this team so special wasn't just the
fact that they were Korean but the fact
that they didn't play like it this was a
group of Koreans who favored the brutal
chaotic complexity of dota over
mastering the skill shots of League the
thing is since there wasn't really any
other top tier Korean team to play
against
there wasn't a Korean style of dota for
MVP to emulate so they invented one in
most games Korean teams are known for
their ability to be calculated
methodical and mechanically unparalleled
MVP on the other hand were prolly an
elegant and most of their strategies
seemed like they were just running at
people they even had a name for it
caveman dota 3 quarterfinal MVP play
like refined cavemen that game I mean
look at oldies draft it looks so good
they have a mix of teamfight control
fighting they have AoE they have magic
damage physical damage they have the
elder Titan combo with the void and then
MVP says I don't care I'm picking PA and
axe and you're gonna lose and we're just
gonna run at you there have been several
iterations of MVP over the years and
suffice to say there is not a single
korean DOTA pro who hasn't passed
through their ranks at one point or
another but they all have one other
thing in common whether you're talking
about march qo forever or Febby these
guys weren't just a lovable underdog
they were actual [ __ ] maniacs
[Music]
Wow okay you gonna eat there
though they formed in 2013
MVP didn't really endear themselves to
dota 2 fans around the world until TI 5
to this day MVPs lower bracket series
against team empire is hailed as one of
those batshit series of dota ever play
he's chosen 42 deliver manicure
[Applause]
miraculously they even managed to finish
top eight at their very first t op they
went on to lose to vici gaming but made
sure not to go down without a fight
can I see trick of the Lincoln speeds at
the same time the superintendent they
can't run this better get it out backup
the search box launched another charge
heating in the house
muffin push him up on top of the cliffs
I need inside the rock face backs
together 77%
breaking the game and we the fiber MVP
the first time they ever actually won a
premier tournament was a dota pit season
4 where they slept evil geniuses the
team that had just one ti5 in the grand
finals
you're in deep now it's there under the
teeth of evil geniuses where is the
extra fallen edge of my culture doesn't
walk into a defensive relocate as well
as in principle the black hole does
absolutely nothing in the day MP jumps
in slides is a PPD and he'll turn for
more in fact he just waiting for the
army slash and then she goes eats on the
work of the bank lines the 5ff a be
perfect that good said fear of Peabody
they drop down low and this allowed the
idiot dropped the hammer down on top of
eg bereave currents to work as easy will
die this can be in this cash be the
grand final winners MVP they just keep
going in deeper they get the stunner or
the surround their nests GJ
will defeat the TI champions evil
geniuses in a whitewashed grand final
3-0 MVP against eg bliss did you think
it was possible come tonight six they
managed to crack into the top six and in
the upper bracket they did the
impossible
they managed to topple two-time major
winners og with nothing but RNG in a
tree
but he gets why I oppose Jeff Dillman
killer ugly flash it up double appeal
permanent
as I head for the faceless boring people
the words all protect materials again as
that
that stuff creditor derby will get the
double kill they come in
the shrunken third toe the chakra
miracle cure finds another holding
miracle they're allowing the activation
JJ
fvp have trashed the two-time major
winners the guys who are perfect to put
a TI win under their belt they may have
to do it just like they did in Frankfurt
the journey through the lower bracket
had a longer journey in that series but
an MVP at Canada
victus here on the TI stage MVP
disbanded in late 2016 and most of their
players jumped between North American
and European organizations often to
great effect with South Korea's dota
infrastructure still in shambles
expatriation was basically their only
option with valve having all but given
up on the region the dream that is
Korean dota is dead gaming is huge in
South Korea but dota not so much not
really what what made you decide to play
dota well it's a game I love and then I
just wish it was you could be big in
Korea so despite being home to what is
the greatest eSports infrastructure in
the world
Korea has effectively expelled its dota
2 players turning them into nomads
mercenaries were able to offer up their
services anywhere that isn't home
still wherever they go and however well
they end up doing they'll always be
remembered for their time on mvp.phoenix
for the time when for a brief shining
moment it seemed like anything was
possible in the world of competitive
dota and when there was never ever such
a thing as too many melee heroes
[Applause]
thanks for watching if you want more
great content just like this be sure to
hit the subscribe button